55-43 was that number and dark mist cat
challenge standard five game on here we
go
team white is ready to double the points
let's go for a minute set up let's see
I've been playing that a bit and we have
it they have it now if I really want it
I have it actually I've been
experimenting with something a bit
different just on my own this silly
little move let's see how bad it is is
it bad
we're gonna see about that this is an
important detail if I did this right
away Knight here as a pain or maybe it's
not no I could have done this so this is
my idea I want to be able to feel kind
of the bishop but get a little bit more
out of my Jeep on I want to get a little
bit more out of my Jeep on so I inserted
a ch3 it's a bit more on the aggressive
side so one idea behind this is what
exactly well it's that maybe I could
throw my opponent up to f5 don't ask to
be cautious about playing this to keep
things close over here I'm not so quick
to do what exactly I'm not so quick to
give this rook play along the h-file so
I don't want to touch this pawn as
otherwise the knight would jump in here
these ponds are battling for the g4
squared I do best to just keep them
sitting if I push forward the bishop can
maybe even be causing me some issues now
if I play my bishop here then I could
jump into this square
Han pushed would weaken this square I
don't want to touch this pawn either it
gives the e5 square up so Bishop e3 we
just Bishop e3 if Knight here I back my
Bishop up and then I'm ready to take
it's good my development complete Queen
d2 as well and you know what I might
even want to move forward
I might even want to play d4 so as a
result maybe Knight here is needed and
this seems not correct why not why not
what's so wrong about that the B pot I
don't have to worry about
sometimes it's this Knight pawn that
will challenge this so do I play b3 and
then this this night could be out of
bounds you could be not out of bonds
once there's a better way to stay he
could be out of play so if I do this
right away well let me let me threaten
to do this I'm in a pin but you know
what maybe even in some cases I could
just give up this rook for the bishop
and play on the dark squares so I'm
looking to throw my deep on in and I
believe that this is something my
opponent should not have allowed so d4
after have I have some concern because
my King is on this diagonal so d4 takes
Knight takes I wouldn't have any pin
issue Bishop takes Queen takes Queen c5
I think I'd be okay in that ending in
large part due to this Knight simply
being out of play this structure alone
the B 3 and C 4 structure means that
this knight struggles and additionally I
might be looking to launch forward there
with d5 take with the night first don't
want to give up my dark square bishop in
fact I want to challenge this guy okay
and now maybe something that I'd look to
do is not exchanged so many pieces yeah
actually I'm going to drop my knight
back because I think what my poem is
ready to do is take my knight and after
the recapture of Bishop c6 and then all
the pieces are they have good squares
but he's still stuck whoa I did not
expect that let's get the Queen opposite
or the rook opposite both Queen
and now this seems very dangerous in
fact this seems just winning now yeah
that's a this was just a losing losing
move rook c1 opposite both king and
queen it's very logical to do that move
but now this is I'm hitting the knight
twice and now captured towards the
center peel open the C file and that's
gonna be game over right
there's no tricky stuff my opponent is
saying whoops it's easy to do you see
that sometimes in the Marazzi bind out
of the Sicilian the Sicilian rotc bind
so how to be as clean as possible about
this just take the knight first or is
there anything better I'm not seeing
anything better let's take the material
and the next order of business is to
make sure that this dark square Bishop
is no longer a problem Bishop here a 5
could be annoying that could generate
some play in fact I don't want the D
file to open I much rather keep it where
it's just the C file that's opened this
seems sensible enough just offer the
Queen exchange I have a for protected
now for the Queen exchange and defend a
- I'm also connecting my rooks one day
one day there might even be a sacrifice
on c6 just to get some attack with IE 5
to follow so a knight here looks very
appealing I'm getting the bishop here
and I'm also getting on the dark squares
so one of these bishops is gonna go
light square or the dark square my
opponent gets to decide but either way I
have two bishops on these adjacent
diagonals take with my queen queen check
here the King has to go into a pin there
it's gonna pin the bishop I can also
just look to do what double on the C
file Queen here one minute 45 time
should not be an issue I have pressure
on the rook as well maybe in some cases
an important detail is knowing that
because you have pressure on this rook
if there's some cases where the rook is
here and the rook takes mine I can maybe
interject the throw-in the Queen takes
first with the check in some cases so
how to just be as squeaky clean as
possible
well the bishop can't move the bishop I
could view as just being pinned can't
move if the bishop moves its mate on the
spot the bishop is pinned so recognizing
that I know that since the bishop can't
move this rook isn't a bother
if this pawn moves I get this pawn
actually if this pawn moves I could
still be throwing in a check so let's
see I could even just do this I probably
should have just been doing this get a
queen trade stick my bishop on this dark
square b6 tax the rook you know so much
for that
okay this this I probably should have
been doing the queen is close to trapped
oh yeah this is picking up a full ruck
now not a full truck I'll be up a full
rock after this Queen here I have this
check I didn't see that though let's
just defend everything let's just defend
everything one minute warning I should
have done this sooner okay let's make
sure I get on this only open file get my
bishop back to this b6 square that's
where I wanted to be the bishop is back
to being pinned back to being pinned
let's stop that from going any further
pawns on dark probably just capture
there okay definitely now I could have
done it sooner than followed up with
this I think on earth oh no the there
would have been a d5 push okay mine is
just gonna play this one out so bishops
check
all right
and just get this pond Bishop here you
can pre move the rest pretty much and
then run that Jeep on my Bishop book out
here to stop the King from making use of
this v8 square to track the pond down
alright yeah it's uh there's a tough pin
there was no recovering from that one
right there a good game let's back up so
proceed with caution I don't know if
this is the right idea but it's it's
something that I was trying I was trying
to get a little bit more out of the
bottom annexed set up I don't know if
it's already a setup
but this h3 and then G for a bit more on
the aggressive side a bit more weakening
I was touching on this part right here I
thought that there's I thought there's a
difference between d3 and g4 like if I
did d4 right now after 95 at eyes f3 d3
and threatens the pun and I believe the
only response to that would be Knight g3
allowing the Queen to guard this f3
square and the bishop would control D 3
and C 4 and then actually it would be
okay maybe in some sense if I play g4
Knight here might seem very appealing
threatening inmate 1 but looking a bit
deeper it'll end up losing time because
after the night plays to g3
I defend those threats and then when f4
comes that will come with the tempo
unless I'm missing something but I don't
think I am so I think that g4 is still
available and maybe even better in some
sense because this deep on then retains
its flexibility and maybe I could get in
d4 in one shot and kind of transposed to
the Sicilian Marazzi bind okay anyhow we
went to some type of Bodmin exceda d4 I
thought is something my opponent should
have been running with or excuse me
Knight d4 this just turns out to be a
waste of time so there's a
some correction that can be made there
and night here it's difficult to find a
good plan isn't it
maybe h4 is not a good idea allowing me
to just do what to control this f6
square maybe you want to be able to
pivot here
that's not sure another idea is to do
what still just castle and then allow
this night to go on that typical journey
by way of 8c 7 e 6 and then jump in here
focusing on d4 so maybe that's a better
thing to go forward with I was feeling
pretty comfortable at this point because
you're losing time and also when the
knight decided to go to this square he
turned out to be a very he was just out
of play right so there's there's an
adjustment there that's my
recommendation really to be able to be
castling instead of h5 to be castling
right here after g4 still go with Castle
maybe Nighy 8c 7 e 6 d 4 and this Bishop
well it's tough to get him doing
anything but just yet but focusing on d4
first it's my main suggestion and maybe
maybe what you could be doing if you
take I recapture out my queen as a
strong post I think no matter what this
is just a good structure no matter what
you do at this point I think I'm I think
the white side is better because of this
guy everything just kind of points in my
eyes to this night on b6 2 ponds are
cancel him out so this was the last part
early I avoid the exchange I have a
space advantage typical idea and now
it's very difficult already this just is
probably already lost right Castle
queenside rep NC one night here probably
no matter what even if you were to
defend it with this you probably still
do that and with two bishops bearing
down and your king side or what's now
the Queen side here did trouble
and then it's just making sure there's
no complications right finishing up
already
good game darkness let me close out of
this and